top three qualities you're looking for
in a woman so
to even get like i wouldn't list you
know beauty or sexiness as one because
to get even get in the door like that's
the requirement of even getting the door
right
so
number one they have to be attractive
well okay but so this is i'm gonna use
these three as like what's going to make
me keep them around okay as like a
girlfriend a potential baby mama
whatever right yes because that's what
i'm actually looking for
multiple oh
exactly okay so what you're saying is
like the attractiveness that's the
obvious we're not even gonna put that in
the top three because it's
self-explanatory now what's going to
keep you there is that where you're
going with this exactly for me it's
going to be loyalty submissiveness and
her ability to improve my social
standing in some way hmm
right okay so so the loyalty we get the
exactly the same principle the social
standing part i want to hear more about
that so okay there's not there's many
ways a woman can do that right okay is
she is she somehow connected in a
network that i can that can help me
financially or help with my business or
whatever does she you know
uh how does she make me look in public
when i walk out the door with her on my
arm does she make me look like the man
is she looking up at me like with
adoring eyes as we're sitting there at
dinner and all the guys who i'm doing
business with around that table are
looking at me with more respect now
mm-hmm that's a massive way of working
because that is a thing it's a huge
thing that's when the guys are powerful
right like and if she's if she's
genuinely beautiful and attractive she's
also going to make me look really good
when i step out with her of course right
so that's something a woman can actually
add value to a man's life with and most
women don't even really
like understand that and you know we
talked about how
kind of masculine a lot of women can be
these days they're actually doing the
opposite by making their man look like a
[ __ ] thanks in public
by talking back to him
disrespecting him
oh my god
i had to pull my buddy aside he was in
love with this girl and she was full on
disrespecting my boy on his birthday no
she's like he doesn't even know what he
likes he's i'm and i remember
i didn't do it that day
and then he's like yeah they ended up
breaking up i was like brother like
the way that your girl was treating you
unacceptable
on your birthday dog i can't even
imagine what's happening not on your
birthday mm-hmm he's like yeah she's
kind of lippy i'm like lippy
you might gotta give her a little foul
limbo
another example of you know behavior
that she can that can make me look
really good in public like okay we're at
the club the other night and my girl was
there and then my boys had their
girlfriends there and every time my
drink was empty
my girl came up and gave me a fresh one
and she's watching me the entire time to
see my drinks such a powerful move
just the fact that she's like my man's
thirsty
she's taking care of me and that makes
me look good to all my boys and by the
way she paid zero for that entire table
i'm assuming yeah so it's the least she
could do yeah exactly that is
reciprocation but that's like that
that's a good point it's the least she
can do yes but a lot of drinking free
and eating free all night off me make
sure that i'm not sending the cup but a
lot of women will will sort of take that
they'll be this their level of
entitlement is quite high yep so they'll
say that they think that makes them look
weak yes they think that makes them look
weak bro it makes you look good baby fat
makes me want to keep her around hey i
just have to i want to say
before i forget this
i think a lot of women have a problem
when the paradigm shifts to where the
man in the relationship is actually the
prize women are conditioned that they're
the prize in society right they're the
prize and i have no problem pursuing you
but i will not chase you
there's a big difference a lot of women
nowadays just want to be chased
endlessly they want to be chased like to
infinity and i'll pursue you i'll
initiate as a man but at the end of the
day once we start to recognize our worth
and our value and realize that we're the
prize then that's where a lot of women
say i'm not used to having to compete
i'm not used to having to bring anything
to the table other than just this body
that i was blessed with that i didn't
even have to work for a lot of times
that i was just naturally blessed with
and that's the problem is women
are not willing to compete because if
they want a man who is you know in the
upper echelon they have to realize that
if you want him exclusively you know me
and my bro right here we talking about
two different things i'm seeking out one
woman he's like bro
i'm not even trying to try to repopulate
right so for me i'm just like yo like
i just recognize in the humblest way
possible that i'm a prize at this point
in life and with that being said it's
very easy to recognize when someone
doesn't view you as a prize and they
wonder why you're not more excited about
being with them and it's just because
you don't recognize my worth but d1 you
got to understand the prize
you're now the prize
but it's because you pursued excellence
what's this the the state the the phrase
in the madness for the red pill chase
excellence not women yeah okay because
the more excellent of a man you become
the more women will show up
you weren't a prize 15 years ago thanks
you were driving around in your 1980
because that's all you could afford at
the time
so your mindset had to upgrade to be
like all right i just went from being
just
a regular old rapper oh no i'm gonna hit
songs labels i'm like my mindset needs
to change right there
so pursue
uh excellent so the people watching this
need to know that too like bro when
you're 19 20 21 years old you might not
be celebrated at that stage in life
korean smart you know and for having
ideas and and being focused and passing
on going to the club you won't get
celebrated then but bro give it five
more years yes give it ten more years
and you will become such a commodity in
society yes the world will be in your
hands respect exactly so all our younger
guys out there
life's a marathon not a sprint okay
don't feel bad about yourselves because
you're 23 years old you don't got no
money and you can't compete
take your time i was broke as [ __ ] when
i was 26 broke as [ __ ] i was a
millionaire by age 35.
give it five years give it 10 years
figure it out you can do it you were
finishing up uh your your your big three
and what was it when i said i said uh i
said submissive i said the ability to
make look good i said loyalty
yeah so for me loyalty is like okay
is she gonna be ex are you gonna be
exclusive to me like my penis has been
inside of you
are you if i see you on like some dude's
boat
the next weekend yeah if you go out on a
girls night the next weekend if you if
you're at the club i'm like that's that
is not a loyal woman okay
instantaneously that disqualifies you as
being loyal
right because if if we have been sexual
together i expect
that you will never
even put yourself in a position to
advertise to another man
but how quickly can you use that like if
you if you're with a girl and you go out
a couple times and you sleep with each
other she doesn't owe you anything after
two days i've had sex with her twice i
expect that to be twice that should be
the be all in wow so one time you'll let
it slide oh one time decides whether
she's a hoe or not
like the one okay one time i sleep with
her and then then i'm looking then i'm
looking for these green flags of these
red flags like i'm looking at the
socials what's she posting on her
socials where's she going what's she
doing is she replying like
how keen is she
so if you like that clip click right
here to watch another or if you want to
watch the entire sauce cast click right
here
[Music]